You know that horrible feeling when your
boss asks you a question and your brain
just locks up? You had the answer 2
minutes ago, but the moment everyone
stares at you, nothing comes to mind and
there's this painful silence in the
room. And now you're thinking to
yourself, "Great. Now I look as stupid
as I think I already am." You feel
terrified to embarrass yourself, but
your body just doesn't give you a
chance. It freezes up, your heart starts
pounding even louder and louder and
louder and instead [music] of you
speaking your thoughts with clarity, you
ramble uncontrollably. But here's what
makes this so frustrating. You're not
stupid. I've seen so many comments on
Reddit of people turning down
promotions, staying quiet and silent in
meetings, and then watching less
qualified colleagues get ahead while
they stay stuck in their career. So, I'm
going to tell you something that you
need to hear, mate. This isn't a you
problem. It's a nervous system problem.
Your brain thinks it's being attacked.
It redirects blood flow away from your
prefrontal cortex, the part that thinks
clearly, and it moves into a fight or
flight mode, which often causes you to
freeze and your body starts to think
it's fighting a two-headed dragon.
Whereas in reality, someone just asked
you a question. So, the goal here is to
stop that automatic fight or flight
response anytime you're put under
pressure and create a new response, one
that allows you to be in control instead
of allowing the moment to control you.
I'm showing you the exact process I've
battle-tested in boardrooms, on
thousands of stages, and even on some of
the biggest podcasts in the world. Let's
solve this once and for all. It's a
three-part process that only takes 5
seconds to execute in the moment. And if
you're thinking, "But then, what if 5
seconds isn't enough time?" Don't worry.
I'll share with you a sneaky strategy
that you can use to buy yourself a
little more time without looking
unprepared. And I'll share those with
you later in the video. When you start
to improve how you show up in these
high-pressure situations, people will no
longer see you as being incompetent or
that quiet person that's that's hard to
work with. They'll start to perceive you
as being confident, articulate, and as
leadership material. So, the three parts
are: one, psychological; two,
physiological; and three, structural.
And I'll show you how to put all three
of these things together, otherwise they
don't work. Part one, psychological. So,
your mind goes blank. Everyone's looking
at you. And here's what most people do.
They start to panic. They rush to fill
the silence. They start speaking their
thinking process, and it comes out as
rambling just to kill the awkward
silence, but now it's even more awkward,
and then it just makes everything worse.
So, what do you do instead?
You pause.
Yep, you pause. I'm talking about a
5-second pause here. Now, I know what
you're thinking, "Then, won't that be
awkward?" But let me say this, it's only
awkward if you make it awkward. I'm
going to say it again, it's only awkward
if you make it awkward. Pausing is
powerful. Here's why. When you pause
intentionally, it makes you look
thoughtful. It signals to everyone in
the room that you're calm, that you're
processing the question, that you're
thinking deeply about the question. The
reason why it might feel weird to you
currently is because most of us have
been conditioned to fill every single
moment of silence. We're terrified of
it. But the most powerful communicators
in the world, they own the pause, and
they're not afraid of the silence.
Imagine you asked me a question, and I
responded immediately like this. "Dino,
I want you to tell me, what are your
thoughts on why growth has stalled this
quarter?" "Oh, I I um you know, there's
so many reasons like um there's the
economy's been up and it's kind of been
down as well, and there's a lot of
moving parts, and you know, like we're
just in a bit of a transition phase.
Yeah. I I'd I'd to say it's it's a
combination of everything that you've
been doing and I've been doing and it's
the best that we can do and at the end
of the day it is what it is.
Did you notice it? It feels surface
level. It feels rushed. It feels like no
thought was put into the response. Now,
imagine if I paused intentionally for 5
seconds to think about my response. What
are your thoughts on why growth has
stalled this quarter?
Do you notice the difference? Need I say
more? When you pause and then you
respond, people are thinking in their
head, "Damn, they're being really
thoughtful about their answer. They
really care about getting it right." And
psychologically, a pause actually works
in your favor because it gives your
brain a moment to reset. And for your
audience, it builds anticipation. It
makes them lean in because now they're
waiting to hear what you're going to say
and that process alone heightens the
perceived value of your answer. Now,
pausing can help, but if your heart is
racing a million miles per hour, then
you're not going to be able to say a
word without fumbling, which is why part
two is critical. If you're like most
people, when you're put on the spot all
of a sudden, not only does your heart
race, but your breathing starts to
become really shallow.
>> [panting]
>> You start to breathe from your chest and
not from your diaphragm. And when you do
this, you're starving your brain of
oxygen. Your prefrontal cortex, again,
that's the part of your brain that helps
you think clearly and speak clearly,
that part shuts down. This is when your
mind goes blank. So, part one,
pause. Part two, you need to take a deep
breath.
Let your shoulders come down and move
them back. Loosen that jaw of yours. Way
too many people walk through the day
with their jaws clenched. And then move
into the thinker pose, which now gives
you context for the 5-second pause that
you're taking because it shows visually
that you're thinking. Otherwise, if you
don't go into thinker a you don't do
this, then sometimes it can look like
you're lagging or you're frozen. And the
beautiful thing about all of this is you
can do all of that in high-stakes
moments and it doesn't seem unnatural.
And when you do this, you activate your
parasympathetic nervous system, which
slows down your heart rate. Deep
breathing signals to your body that
you're calm. And when your body is calm,
your mind can actually function well. At
first, it's going to feel a little bit
weird, but remember, it's not weird,
it's just unfamiliar. And the more you
do it, the more automatic this starts to
become. So, practice this often. Part
three, structural. So, now you've
paused. You've taken that deep breath.
Your mind is clear, your body is calm,
but then the question is, what do you do
with that time and space now that you've
got in your mind? What do you do with
your mind? This is where frameworks come
in. You see, most people ramble when
they get asked a really difficult
question, because as they're trying to
answer that big question, they end up
speaking out their thinking process. And
that's why it sounds like it's all over
the place. This is why we pause before
we speak, so we can do our thinking, so
we can apply frameworks, distill the
thinking, and then speak.
And when you follow this formula, what
you say sounds clear, coherent, and
concise. The simplest framework you can
apply in these high-pressure situations,
when someone asks you something very
difficult, broad, and complex, is this:
the one thing. Let me show you exactly
how this one thing framework works. What
are your thoughts on why growth has
stalled this quarter?
The one thing that's really stalling our
growth this quarter is a drop in
high-quality leads at the top of funnel.
Once we fix that, we'll start to see
more conversions immediately. Now,
that's what I'm talking about. This type
of communication, that's what gets
people like him promoted. See how
seamless my response was? By starting my
response with the one thing, it created
a constraint. I can't talk about the 20
things that's currently going on in my
mind. I had to prioritize the 20 things,
pick the one most impactful and
important thing, and then this
constraint that I set in the first three
words of my sentence allows me now to
focus and be more concise and coherent.
I use this and do this all the time with
frameworks. You're now able to build
your response in real time. And it
sounds like you've got your
together. And the one thing is a part of
a much bigger framework called 3-2-1.
And I teach this in depth in a free
2-hour training to help you speak with
more structure, more clarity, and more
confidence while under pressure. We nerd
out on many other frameworks during this
training. So, if you want to learn more,
click the link in the description below
or scan the QR code that's currently on
screen. Now, I did promise you earlier,
"Vin, what what what what do I do if I
need more than 5 seconds? What if it's
not enough?" Well, there's one thing you
can do here. You can ask a question to
get more clarity. Now, this does two
things. One, it buys you an extra 10 to
15 seconds for you to think as you're
asking the question and as they're
replying to that question. Two, it gives
you an opportunity to clarify and create
more clarity before you formulate your
answer, which ultimately improves the
quality of your answer. So, this is an
amazing technique. For example, if
someone asked me, "Vin, can you help me
understand content marketing?" I can ask
a question while I'm trying to formulate
my answer and get more clarity at the
same time by asking in return, "Sure,
but first tell me more. Are you wanting
to understand content marketing from a
high level or is there a specific
platform you'd like me to focus my
answer on?"
See what I just did there? I'm not
stalling for stalling's sake. I'm asking
a question seeking clarity. And the
byproduct? I've actually just bought
myself more time. And while they're
answering you, you're selecting the
optimal framework, this one right here,
the optimal framework that you're going
to use to package your reply with. And
if you came along to two-hour training
that's down below or the QR code, you're
going to have three incredible
frameworks that you can use anytime
moving forward into the future. So there
you go. If you master these three
things, owning the pause to give you
time to think, [music] diaphragmatic
breathing to calm your body, and using
frameworks to calm your mind, you'll
never freeze under pressure again.
You'll stop turning down opportunities,
you'll stop watching other people get
ahead while you're stuck on the start
line, and you'll start showing up as the
confident, articulate person you [music]
know you can be. Click subscribe, hit
the thumbs up. Come on.
And if you want to go deeper down the
rabbit hole of communication, we've got
a beautiful video lined up for you just
here. Click that.